[Music]
let's go to johnny in utah hey johnny
what's up brother
ah not a lot how are you guys doing
today good man how are you
good uh thanks for taking my call um
my question kind of falls more on the
category of uh some of the other calls
earlier today where it's kind of more of
a confirmation uh
i have a credit card that doesn't have a
balance on it i'm debt-free you know all
that good jazz and uh
i just have a fundamental value to it i
just um
just can't seem to get rid of it is it
cute
well i wish it was does it make you feel
safe why can't you get rid of it why is
it sentimental
uh just because it's like uh i didn't
really have you know growing up i didn't
really have a
you know support system and all that and
so um
there was a time in my life and i had a
lot of debt and i had to have it so to
say
but i'm not there anymore now you know
thankfully i'm good financially healthy
uh financially healthy to say
yeah so tell me about
you had to have it tell me about that
uh well originally
um when i started kind of second dead on
it it was just more of like
you know i needed it for rent i was just
i was going out of a bad relationship at
the time
um
but but why did you need that credit
card for rent why'd you need like you're
coming out of a bad relationship why did
you need a credit card to help exit a
bad relationship
uh just pretty much to be able to
i didn't want to leave my partner
hanging at the time so i had to cover
that half of the rent and then you know
find a new place and at the time i just
didn't have the money for it so young
and dumb but
so but what i'm trying to get you to is
you didn't need it
but it helped you do things that you
wanted to do
is that fair yeah
yeah that'd be a fair salesman okay okay
and i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
poke at you anything like that what i'm
trying to do is is
you've got some tight emotion this thing
is wound into you somehow
and it sounds like it's wound into
the
the the
the dissolution of a of a relationship
that meant something to you of a tough
season in your life
and it's become a security blanket it's
become something that you hang on to as
a just in case of a just in case
and so what i'm trying to unwind here is
you don't need it like you need air or
water
you don't even need it financially are
you out of debt now
yes sir i am yeah man do you have an
emergency fund
i do six months brother that should be
sentimental not a piece of plastic that
a company printed out and their name on
it yeah
would you cut it up on the phone with us
or is that too hard for you
what was that would you ever cut this
card up on the phone right now while
we're on the line
uh
you said you needed confirmation so you
know what you need to cut it right now
but yeah i'll just get rid of it no no
no no you have it on you you love it you
have it on i pictured you holding it
while you called us or on a necklace
no it's just it's just
pull it out and cut it up
dude cut it up today you can call him up
and cancel and tell him dave ramsey told
you to do whatever you got to do but you
need to get this out of your life you're
in a different place you work so hard to
get out of debt and you know you're
never going back again
let that be sentimental the hard work
your never again moment where you said
never again am i gonna have to rely on a
credit card to pay rent
you've done so much hard work to get to
this point and now
you're sentimental over a literal piece
of plastic just take the emotion out and
just look at it logically a company
printed out a piece of plastic and gave
you money
not as a gift but so that they could
make money off of you i want you to get
angry at this company angry at this card
cut it up put it in an ornament put it
on your christmas tree how's that for
sentimental
i probably won't put it on three but
like yeah that definitely but you're
keeping in your wallet there's not much
of a difference is there yeah or cut it
up and mail it to us cut it up and set
it in a fire i like that idea john will
shoot it
i'm not gonna shoot it but
here's the thing you know what you need
to do and i i will i'll honor the fact
that this thing has woven itself into
you but as george said i want you to
flip that connection around
it is not something that's kept you safe
it's something that's kept you trapped
it's something that's kept you enslaved
be angry at this thing that has grown
roots into your soul and it's time for
it to go and you've done all the hard
work already
call it and cancel it
do we have your word in front of the
entire country
today's a day
yesterday's the day
i don't want it anymore
it's awesome today's the day today's the
day you are free my brother
congratulations i'm excited